la fiscalía de México identificó a los
presuntos responsables de la muerte de
39 personas durante el incendio en una
estación migratoria en la frontera norte
del país
se tienen identificados
inicialmente ocho personas probablemente
responsables de los hechos
dos agentes federales
un agente Estatal de migración así como
cinco elementos de la empresa de
seguridad privada quienes ya están
rindiendo sus declaraciones
ministeriales correspondientes la
fiscalía aseguró que los servidores
públicos no se apegaron a los protocolos
de protección a la vida y que no
reaccionaron apropiadamente para evacuar
a los migrantes en medio del fuego
razones por las que el órgano judicial
investigará un presunto homicidio se
inició la carpeta por el delito de
homicidio y por el delito de daño en
propiedad ajena pero de acuerdo a las
investigaciones se analizarán otros
delitos las personas no están detenidas
hasta que no exista esta orden de
aprehensión
pero aunque el presidente mexicano
aseguró que se deben tomar medidas y no
debe haber impunidad sobre los hechos
familiares de las víctimas y activistas
de Derechos Humanos salieron a las
calles de la capital para exigir
justicia bajo la premisa no murieron los
mataron
Ya basta de tanto perseguir acribillar
extorsionar robar violentar los derechos
de los migrantes Ya basta de asesinar Ya
basta de un discurso de que son
Bienvenidos a México y resulta que la
realidad es otra prefirieron dejarlos
morir quemados y asfixiados que dejarlos
salir no Y eso nos debe de decir mucho
respecto de Cuál es la política
migratoria en México Esa es la política
primero muerte antes de que yo te deje
pasar el incendio se dio cuando México
lucha por hacer frente a niveles récord
del tránsito migratorio hacia Estados
Unidos Washington por su parte dijo que
estaba siguiendo de cerca la situación y
ofreció ayuda a las autoridades
mexicanas